ya más de una semana después del
terremoto del pasado lunes por la
madrugada que sacudió el sureste de
Turquía y al norte de Siria siguen
saliendo personas de debajo de los
escombros con vida eso sí lo hacen muy
pocos ya son muy pocos así Cada día
salen y los que lo consiguen hoy por
ejemplo han sido unos pocos cuantos
menos de 10 casi son una inmensa mayoría
de todos los cuerpos que son retomados
hoy han salido con vida al menos varios
niños sobre todo en la provincia de
cajamarcaras a diamani en antakya en
hatay que es la ahora mismo la más
afectada y con la que suma más muertos
este terremoto de hecho ayer estuvimos
en esa ciudad en Antioquia en anquia y
veíamos como en muchos sitios de rescate
muchas los equipos de rescate estaban
directamente intentando excavar de los
escombros con las excavadoras ya
habiendo perdido toda esperanza de sacar
a nadie de comida es algo que ocurre en
la gran mayoría de edificios de ruidos
en esa ciudad según nos dice en el 90%
de la ciudad está completamente
destruida hoy mismo estábamos hablando
con una de las personas que tiene que
decidir qué va a pasar con estas
ciudades son ahora mismo la región de
adana donde nos encontramos también las
otras colindantes se ha llenado de ya no
de equipos de rescate que muchos Están
volviendo o a sus países o a sus bases
sino de personas y miembros del
Ministerio de planificación urbanística
de Turquía que están ahora mismo
entrando edificio edificio a ver los
daños estructurales para saber si estos
edificios pueden ser habitables en un
futuro o no este hombre de este
ministerio nos contaba hace unos minutos
que cree que en muchas ciudades incluida
Antioquia el número de edificios de
ruidos probablemente sea en torno al
100% de todas las viviendas